we've talked before about whether we
believe that Donald Trump is actually
anti-abortion or as he describes it
pro-life he's been pro-choice most of
his life he told the story about how his
mind was changed on the abortion issue
after someone he knew decided not to
have an abortion and it turned out to be
a really great kid that Donald Trump
likes fine right the specifics of trumps
story don't matter as much to me as
whether we are going to see hardline
abortion legislation passed because of
those emboldened by the election of
Donald Trump and we are seeing exactly
that there's an Indiana lawmaker state
Rep Kurt knisley who said a couple of
days ago that he plans to introduce a
bill which would outlaw and criminalize
all forms of abortion in Indiana now you
might be waiting for me to say something
like except in cases of or after X
number of weeks but no that is not the
proposal that curtain is Lee says he
will put forward it will be just a ban
on abortion it will be called the
protection at conception bill or act and
this will be happening in January when
the General Assembly convenes at the
same time that president elected Donald
will be sworn in now under this proposal
all abortions would be a crime uh
prosecutors could file charges against
anybody who participates in the
procedure the goshen Republican Goshen
Indiana Republican saying you would
treat the death of an unborn child like
you would any other human being he also
said it's time to bring roe v wade to
its logical conclusion my goal is to
deregulate abortion right out of
existence in Indiana think about that
for a second he's calling the ban of all
abortions deregulation this is a trick
that the Republican Party has been using
for decades the plan would delete
regulations permitting abortion
therefore according to this harebrained
backwards bizarro world logic it is
deregulation think about that you're
making a government decision to ban a
particular medical procedure and
prosecute those involved with it that is
regulation that is a government
restriction Pat but these backwards
right wingers are framing this as if
they're going to deregulate by making
abortion illegal it's like they're
trying to use certain buzz words that
will pull well right yeah but if you
look at a Donald Trump's recent 60
minutes interview he seems to
demonstrate no understanding of the
consequences of overturning Roe vs. Wade
yeah sure it will be up to the States
but he says that people who want to
still have abortions could just go to
another state a lot of people can afford
that a lot of people don't have the
means to do that Donald Trump can't
imagine really any world where you can't
just travel from one state to another I
mean the guy visited six states a day
with his personal Boeing 757 during the
entire campaign he can't really imagine
what it means that just go to another
state even in places like Texas large
states without going to another state
you could have to drive eight or ten
hours or of course if you don't have a
car then you've gotta buy a bus ticket a
blah blah blah blah there's just no
concept whatsoever of what this would
actually mean and the the sort of good
news is that assuming roe v wade stands
this indiana anti-abortion bill would
basically definitely be considered
unconstitutional we ruled
unconstitutional the problem is that
conservative activists are very
emboldened by Donald Trump's election
and his promise to put up judges on the
Supreme Court who might overturn roe v
wade that they acknowledge yet right now
it would be tough to pass something like
this but after we get those changes on
the Supreme Court and roe v wade is done
away with these types of abortion bans
could actually pass Trump has promised
to appoint anti-abortion judges to the
high court and this could be truly a
disaster and it it really appears that
Indiana Republicans are not going to be
satisfied until they can go back seven
years nearly to the 1950s in more ways
than one and of course the the logical
thing would be fine Republicans will get
rid of abortion but bill increase the
budgets for things like education and
contraception and foster care and
welfare to compensate for the increased
number of children right wrong of course
they wouldn't do that because
Republicans care about the fetus but not
about the child and we've heard this
time and again we've made this critique
time and again we know how to reduce the
number of abortions that people say seek
out that women seek out you have
comprehensive sex education you have
access to contraception which we know
prevents people from getting pregnant
and being pregnant is one of the
prerequisites to having an abortion and
they refuse to do it they continue to
refuse to do it because this is about
politics and this is about fundraising
and this is about pandering to the most
extreme religious right elements of
Trump and the Republican base and
electorate this is not actually about
making decisions that are good for
people and good for women and good for
parents and good for kids we know that
and this is going to be a real danger
during the upcoming President Donald
administration today's program is made
possible in part by frame bridge which
allows you to custom frame artwork of
yours I tried this the other day I have
a really great picture that I took in
Argentina on my last trip there and I
uploaded the picture to frame bridge I
was able to select the matting I was
able to select the frame itself I'm
pretty clueless on this so I I more than
likely should have taken advantage of
the free frame bridge advisory service
which will actually give you some
suggestions of the right matting in
color and frame etc but I didn't do that
and I'm optimistic that it is still
going to turn out really really well if
you're not able to upload your artwork
to frame bridge you can actually
physically send it in that also applies
if you want to have like a jersey or
some other kind of flag or memorabilia
brained they use real wood moldings
acid-free mat board foam board etc and
they also have prices
starting at thirty nine dollars and
shipping is all free you can go to frame
bridge dot-com and use promo code Pakman
that's frame bridge dot-com promo code
Pakman PA ke ma n and you will save an
extra fifteen percent off of your first
order check it out